[موسيقى]
مساء الخير جوله جديده في الاعلام العبري
وما يجري داخل دوله الاحتلال اسرائيل في
صحبه صديقنا الدكتور احمد فؤاد استاذ
العبري الحديث والفكر الصهيوني مساء الخير
معال الدكتور سنور سيد بيه صديقي العزيز
كان في تسريبات
مهمه لصحيفه اكثر من صحيفه يعني ولكن
اعتقد يدعوت احر نوت كان لها نصيب الاسد
انها تحدثت عن روايه جديده لما حدث يوم 7
اكتوبر
2023 صحيح احنا عندنا روايه سائده بدات
التسريبات الاسرائيليه تكشف لنا عن حقائق
جديده هل ممكن نفهم ما يعني اهم التسريبات
اللي نشرتها يدعو احران اه طبعا هم
بيحولوا هذه الروايه الى تابو الى ممنوع
اللمس احنا مش عارفين ايه بقى الروايه
السائده الاول انها تنقدها ا اوضح صح
الروايه السائده ان كان في حفله فيها
مدنيين وان حماس هجمت على هذه الحفله
وقتلتهم واخذت مجموعه كبيره منهم اسر فهذه
الروايه ا اصبحت ممنوع ان انت تشكك فيها
وان كان في اطفال تم قتلهم وقطع رؤسهم وان
كان في اغتصاب فالروائي ما تسرب في الايام
الماضيه يضرب هذه الروايه في مقتل واحد ان
في تحقيقات داخل سلاح الطيران انتم ليه ما
جيتوش بسرعه انقذت المجموعه اللي بتتعرض
للهجوم غلاف غزه ليه سقط بالكامل قواعد
عسكريه سقطت معسكرات وتجمعات سكنيه فده
كان من ضمن الاسئله فرو الروايه الروايه
هو من روى من يعني يعني يعني م دي كان
التحقيقات مع من مع الطيرين مع السلطات
الاسرائيليه مع قا اه سلاح الطيران بيحقق
مع الطيرين بيقول لهم انتم مشيتوا ازاي
عملته ايه اللي تدخل يوم 7 اكتوبر للسيطره
على الهجوم الحمساوي بالضبط عظيم هذه
التحقيق تسربت الى صحيفه يد حنوت ا عظيم
بقى اهم ملخص هذه التسريبات ايه ملخص هذه
التسريبات ان اللي انطلق وراح اولا جاء من
اقصى الشمال كان في معسكرات ملاصقه لم تت
تحرك وترسل مروحيات دي اول علامه استفهام
لماذا لم تتحرك القاعده
الملاصقه لغزه القريبه من غزه المنطقي
انما اللي حصل ان مابين الساعه 7 ونص الى
8 صباحا يعني بعد حوالي ساعتين من بدء
الهجوم وصلت مروحيتين وبضع مسيرات ف
ابتدوا دي وفق روايتهم بالنص ابتدوا
يلاحظوا ان هم مش قادرين يفروا روا بين من
الجندي الاسرائيلي ومن المخرب وفق تعبيرهم
اللي هو المقاوم الفلسطيني وان في نفس
الوقت مش قادر يفرق داخل القواعد العسكريه
مش قادر يفرق داخل التجمعات السكنيه بين
المدني الاسرائيلي وبين المخرب الفلسطيني
ف مع ذلك استمر
الضرب ايه اللي بيحصل ان انا توجهت للجدار
السياج الامني الفاصل بين اراضي 48 وغزه
والقيت قنابل وصواريخ
ثقيله تمام فده بعد فتره وتيرته ابتدت تقل
احنا هنبتدي
نستهدف اللي بيجري احنا عايزين نوقف كلام
الطيارين اه اللي بيجري هو ده المخرب
فالعنوان بتاع ايدوت احنط يعني صادم شويه
ان هو بيقول ايه تضليل حماس وخداعها
لمروحيات الجيش الاسرائيلي وضع سلاح
الطيران في اليوم الاول للحرب ده المنشط
بالترجمه الحرفيه فبيقول ان كان في
تعليمات لجيش حماس حسب وصفهم بلا يجروا
بلا يركضوا وان هم هيخدوا الطيارين
وبالفعل الخداع ده تم فده معناه ان الضرب
اولا كان عشوائي ثانيا كان موجه للايصال
لانه حماس توقعت ان هم هيضربوا الفرين فهي
فظهروا ان هم اسين زبوا اماكنهم والللي
جري اللي هم اليهود الخائفين ف بالضبط
ممكن يكون رحبوا بالمرايات كمان اه كمان
كوع من التضليل اه وده يقول لنا ا تفسير
عدد القتلى الكبير وفقا للروايه
الاسرائيليه 1400 1400 اه فالحديث حاليا
ان على الاقل 200 منهم برصاص اسرائيلي اه
اه في في ضوء ان لم يتم التمييز ومع ذلك
استمر الضرب والله ده الكلام ده بيتفق انا
كان في مؤتمر صحفي امبارح للمتحدث باسم
حماس اللي هو اسامه حمدان مظبوط صحيح قال
روايه مشابهه قال احنا كانت روايتنا
كالاتي الروايه بتاعتنا ان احنا هجمنا على
الوحده العسكريه المسؤوله عن قطاع غزه صح
وده كان هدفنا ام فكره بقى هجوم كتائب
القسام على مدنيين وحفله هو بيقول هذا لم
يحدث من جانبنا وبعدين استشهد هو بصحيفه
اخرى اظن اريتس وقال ان من هجم والحق
خسائر كبيره ب بهؤلاء يعني كان الطيران
الاسرائيلي بس اظن اكيد حماس راحت هناك
يعني ما انا هقول لحضرتك عشان الصوره تتضح
برض يعني هو تبين ان وفق ارتس ان منظمي
هذه الحفله واللي مدير مكتب نتنياهو قال
هذه الحفله هي اللي جابت علينا الوبال
فابتدع ينتقدوه ان في مشكله في الحفله مش
مشكله في في حماس هو رايه كده انتقدوا مين
انتقدوا نتنياهو ولا انتقدوا مدير مكتب
نتنياهو اللي بيقول ان الحفله دي هي سبب
المشاكل دي كلها فهو بيقول ايه الارت
تقريرها بيقول ايه بيقول ان لم يكن من
المقرر ان تكون هناك حفله يوم السبت مساء
السبت بيبدا من جمعه المغرب فهم كانوا
بالمئات في هذه الحفله التي امتدت يوم
اضافي ما كانش من المقرر انها تستمر
فاستمرت يوم الجمعه
بالليل يوم اضافي فيوم السبت الصبح اللي
هو الهجوم بدا معاه الساعه 6:00 تقريبا
صباحا كان جال لهم تعليمات من الشرطه بان
السواري دي طلعت اجروا فضوا الحفله فهم
دول اللي كانوا بيجروا اللي الطيرين
شايفين الناس بتجري فكان هم كانوا
الموجودين في الحفله وبناء على تعليمات
الشرطه عشان الصور تتضح اكتر طب والشرطه
حذرتهم من ايه ان في صواريخ دلوقتي لازم
صواريخ من الطيران الاسرائيلي لا صواريخ
اللي هي القسام التي تتجه الى عمق لارباك
عمق الاراضي الاسرائيليه اللي تواز مع
الهجوم اه بالظبط فهو الفكره ان لما
الشرطه لقت اولا كان الحفله دي مع قوه ل
تمينه اه وده برض مسكوت عنه في الاعلام
الاسرائيلي اللي يتم ابرازه ان دول مجموعه
من المدنيين العزل تم الهجوم عليهم فالشرط
ابتدت ت تقضم وتديهم اوامر بالتليفون
بالامر المباشر بالركض والفرار من هذا
المكان الانصراف ففي عشان تكتمل الصوره في
واحده ط في التلفزيون الاسرائيلي من
المحتجزات سابقا الذين في الفوضى هربت كان
على الجانب المحتجزين من جانب كتائب
القسام اه ت القوات ال فصائل المقاومه
وصلت وهم كانوا في الحفله اه فبناء على
تعليمات الشرطه هربوا وا استخبوا في
احد التجمعات السكنيه المجاوره القوات
بتاعه حماس فصائل حماس فصال المقاومه لحقت
بيهم فاول ملاحظه قالوا ان دي هي اللي
بتحكي المحتجزه السابقه بتقول لقوا ان
التنوره قصيره فدوني
بسروال بيسموه هدومي تلبسها يعني اه
برموضه واسع وادوني زي قميص كده للنصف
العلوي ف طبعا المذيع عمال اقطعها مش
عاجبها ان دول بيتعاملوا كويس لان الروايه
ان هم
بيغتصبوا فايه الجزء اللي مثير للسخريه
برض ان هي وقائد خاطفين يعني بقى فيهم
تفاهم هي الوسيطه بين المحتجزين وبين
المجموعه اللي مش عارفه عبري والقائد
موجود ومعاه حد بيترجم له عبري انما هو
القائد المسؤول فهو اللي امر بكذا وكذا
وكذا من ضمن الاوامر قال لها فين تليفونك
الموبايل بتاعك الهاتف بتاعك عشان تطلبي
من لو تعرفي حد من الجيش يجي او من شرطه
تبلغهم على الرقم المختصر ويبدو ان هم
كانوا عايزين عاين يعملوا كمين ان هم
يختطفه او يقصروا عدد من العسكريين مش
عايزين نماذج دي مش عايزين المدنيين
واتصلت برقم
الهاتف القصير لشرطه الاحتلال وابتدت
توبخه بناء على تعليمات انتوا ليه ما
جيتوش انتوا ابتدت الساعه اعه العصر الناس
تيجي ضربوا على صديقها يعني صديقها اللي
هو معاها في الحفله كان موجود معاها لا
لقوا ان هم بيضربوا عشوائي عايزين يخشوا
يمسحوا
المكانه شرطه الاحتلال بدل ما تحررهم او
تتفاوض اطلقت النيران على الاسرائيلي
صدقها ا معالي الدكتور وفقا للتسريبات
اللي هي عباره عن تحقيقات ما بين الطيارين
الاسرائيليين اللي شاركوا في مواجهه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه يوم 7 اكتوبر واللي
تسربت الى يدعوه احرنوت كالتالي اي انه
اولا اول خلل انه الطيران الاسرائيلي شارك
من قاع قاعده بعيده وهناك علامه استفهام
على عدم مشاركه طيارين وعسكريين كانوا في
قاعده عسكريه قريبه ده اول علامه استفهام
اثنين كان في ارتباك اخذ عده اشكال الاول
المهمه المكلف بها التيار انه وجد مش
متاكد يعني اقدر ازاي احدد اهدافي فضرب
يعني قطاعي كده عش ضرب عشوائي وغالبا هو
كان بيسته دف السياج ايوه اللي كان بيحيض
بغزه بحيث انه يمنع تدفق الناس ايوه ثم
بدا عاوز يبقى سلكتف بقى فبدا عاوز يحاول
يختار المخربين وفقا لتعبيره اي فهو بدا
يضرب اللي هو بيجره علم لاحقا انه حماس
توقعت هذه الخطوه فطلبت من عناصرها ان
يلزموا اماكنهم وربما حيوا الطيران كمان
وفقا لروايتك امعانا في خداعهم فمن قتل هو
من كان يجري من اليه صحيح عشان الروايه
تكتمل زي ما انت فهمتها لي كده انه الشرطه
كانت سبقت وطلبت من
هؤلاء المستوطنين او المحتفلين اللي كانوا
في حفله
كبيره انه اجروا بسرعه لانه تواكب مع
الهجوم المباشر صواريخ من قطاع غزه فده
ضاعف عدد الفرين وضاعف عدد الاهداف اللي
استهدفها الطيران من اليهود عايز اضيف بس
جمله ان الطيرين والمشغل للطائرات المسيره
كانوا بيخلفوا الاوامر كل واحد بيجتهد
يعني الاوامر عند الضرب العشوائي او الضرب
او اوقف الضرب او انتظر هو كان بيقيم
الموقف حسب ما هو شايف بقى يعني هو مش
فاهم بيحاول يفهم بيحاول يحط التاتش بس
المشكله الاساسيه السيد ان هو بيستخدم
اسلحه ثقيله اه يعني لو في قر على
موتوسيكل احنا شفنا على موتوسيكل واححد
قر و وهو الاسير كمان اللي سايق
الموتوسيكل
فالمشاهد دي لما تربطها بحرائق جثث
محروقه القسام ما عندوش الاليه ان هو يحرق
ما عندوش الاسلحه اه اه ما عندوش الاسلحه
عنده ار بيجي
بيدمر مبنى انما محرقش وطبعا في تسريبات
كتيره محتاجين نعرفها او الصوره تطح لنا
لان برض يعني الفلسطينيين ما بيقولوا لناش
اجابه بيقولوا احنا كنا بنستهبل ام اذا
كان بيسته دف العسكريين فقط هو خد سيدات
مسنات يعمل بهم ايه مثلا افسر لسيادتك لان
ده سؤال مهم جدا هو المشكله ان لما تم فتح
ثغرات في السياج اللي هو الامني اللي بين
48 وغزه عبر اهالي ليس فصائل مقاومه فقط
كان في نوع من الفوضى عدم التنظيم كل واحد
برض اجتهد يعني بقول ان في يعني عشوائيه
من الجانب اليهودي وعشوائيه من الجانب
الفلسطيني اه بالضبط فهو ده كان في اجتهاد
شخصي وعارف حضرتك انت انت بيقول لك تسليم
اهالي ده خطف اهالي لدرجه ان حماس بتقول
انا لا اعلم اين كل الرهائن انا لسه هتصل
بالاهالي شوف انت محتجز كام فين وه تسلمهم
لي امتى وازاي ومش عاوز طبعا مسيرات تصوره
وهو بيستلم وهو بيسال فعاوز بالتالي
الصفقه بتاعه عمليه الهدنه تتم الهدنه دي
تتم بعيد عن تعريض من احتجز
ا ئ
لجانب الا انا بيجيلي تعليقات كتيره او
بيجي لنا يقول من فضلك ما تستخدم رهائن
تمام هي بس عموما بالنسبه
للتوصيف الموضوعي بقطع النظر عن الميول
انا عندي الاسير اللي هو العسكري اللي
اخذت المقاومه وعندي ناس كانوا زي السيدات
المسنات دول اخذهم سواء من اهالي او من اي
فصائل اخرى هو في حقيقه الامر يعد رهينا
عاوز تسميه محتجز ماشي اه ما قريبه مرهين
بس هو الفكره ان هم عبقى على المقاومه
عشان كده اس عايزه تاخدهم ببلاش اه فعلا
ققول لك خليهم عندك عالجهم اه اعمل بيبي
سيتر يعني ادي الاطفال كده هو واضح ان
اللي خدهم مش ناس محترفه اه مش محترفين
وبقوا مع يبقى اخلاقي وفعلا اقتصادي
والعنايه بيهم ف الموضوع مركب لكن في
النهايه هو رب اره النافعه ان ذكر الجميع
بان في اطفال في الجانب الاسرائيلي في
سجون الاحتلال في اطفال ونساء عظيم جدا
طيب اذا ما تركنا هذه التسريبات المهمه
اللي بتكشف لنا عن يعني جزء بسيط جدا م ما
حدث يوم 7ب ومحتاجين وقت كتير قوي عشان
نفهم اللي حصل يعني كان في مجلس وزراء
امني موسع
اظن امس 19 نوفمبر مضبوط صحيح هل في اي
اخبار حصلت فيه او اي معلومات ذات اهميه
ما تصرب عن هذا الاجتماع يعني ذو دلاله في
تقديري ان اصبع الاتهام حاليا وكبش الفداء
ليس فقط نتنياهو وكن بنج فير فالحديث مع
بنج فير كان حاد جدا من المجموعه المنوه
ليه
داخل المجلس الوزراء الامني الموسع كان في
حده خاصه من ايزن كوت رئيس الاركان السابق
وحاليا هو وزير في حكومه الطوارئ يعني
يعني انت عارف حضرتك الطريقه بتاع زكي بدر
كان في تجاوز الجلسه الشهيره في اللي عايز
يدور على اليوتيوب على زكي بدر وزير
الداخل مصر في جلسه شهيره تجاوز فيها
للغايه في مجلس الشعب ضد المعارضين انذاك
فهو استخدم تقريبا نفس المصطلحات او نفس
التجاوزات بيقول له ما تتكلمش لا تتدخل
انا بيكلم وزير الامن الداخلي الحالي
القومي اه وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
بينج فير اللي هو المستوطن اللي هو
المتطرف اللي عمل الاعتداءات على الضفه
الغربيه واشعل الموقف اللي تدخل في الحرم
القدسي بانتهاكات
وتدنيس فده فزن كت بيقول له ايه بقى ز كنت
ما تتكلمش انا ما بسالك احنا بنتكلم عن
مسؤوليه الجيش الاسرائيلي امام القانون
الدولي انا هو واضح ان ده برض الكابوس
والهاجس اللي كله عشان كده بيخبوا وشوش
الناس وشوش الجنود جنود الاحتلال في
العمليات الاسرائيليه داخل غزه بيتم
اخفاءها والله انا كنت عايز اسالك السؤال
ده على فكره يعني ليه بيخف وجوه الجرو لان
سبق ان في ناس نزلت في لندن عشان من ال
اره وتم منعهم سيفي ليفني وبعض الجنرالات
وزير خارجيه السابقه وكان شغاله في
الموساد كادر مهم ف وكانت زعيمه حزب قديمه
فلما بتنزل لندن يقول لها ما تنزلوش انا
اخدك على المحكمه انت مطلوبه للتحقيق تحبي
تروحي فتقول لا ماحبش طبعا ارجع على
اسرائيل مالها اسرائيل فده حصل مع جنرالات
شاركوا في معارك قبل كده في غزه بشكل خاص
في دول المختلفه الدول مختلف وبالتالي
بيخف الوجو عتالي هم ليه تجربه بالاسماء
بالوقائع باليوم وطبعا ده مش عايزين العبق
ده فبيبقي جوه مجلس الوزراء الامن الموسع
اذن كوت بيقول الجيش ايه موقفه طب احنا
نتحاكم فدلوقتي الراجل بيقا طع وبيتكلم
بسخريه اللي هو مين بينج فير وزير الامن
القو بيقول لي انتم دخلت لهم وقود وانا
بعترض انت ناقص دخلهم قوه اه يلعبوا يعني
ياه ايه ده فالناس ضحكت لكن ايذن كوت
ارضعه وكان حدا وواضح ان في اصبع اتهام
موجهه لبنج فير وفي ارتباك بشان المسؤوليه
القانونيه على جيش الاحتلال وعلى قدر هو
مش اتهام واحد لبن غفير بن غفير ده يعني
هو قال كده قال انا عندي 45 اتهام سابق من
النيابه الاسرائيليه فبيقول له انت هتروح
لهاي انت عارف لهاي ق لهم ايه يعني انا
عندي خمسه 4 اتهام
سابق على كل الاحوال انت اجبت لنا على
سؤال مهم لماذا يخفي جنود الجيش
الاسرائيلي او جيش الاحتلال وجوههم اذا
كانت المقاومه بتعمل ده لان هي طبعا الطرف
الاضعف لما بيواجه جيش كبير وعاوز انه
يتخفى في الشوارع لكن جيش الاحتلال بيخب
واجهه ليه فانت قلت لنا خوفا من الملاحقه
قانونيه القادمه عندما تنتهي الحرب طيب في
موضوع ثاني بيتم ال حديث عنه وهو التمييز
بشده ضد بعض الاقليات بديهي يعني انه في
ملاحقات لكل من يعيش من الفلسطينيين داخل
الضفه الغربيه ودي قصه هكلمك عنها في يقت
الاح لكن حتى داخل اسرائيل بروبر زي ما
بيقولوا يعني داخل حدود 48 في بعض
الاقليات زي الدروس زي بعض البدو العرب
واضح ان عاد الحديث يتجدد عن اضطهادهم رغم
تعاون بعضهم الكامل مع جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يعني زي ما حضرتك اشرت كده في
مشكله كبيره جدا في اسرائيل حاليا خاصه
بالدروز اللي في جزء منهم في هربه الجولان
ويرفضون التعاون مع جيش الاحتلال بالعكس
بيحت قروه و بيرفعوا اعلامهم وعلى استعداد
ان هم يقاوموها تيسر ذلك ا انما في مجموعه
كبيره منذ عقود انضمت لصفوف الجيش بالتطوع
تم تجنيدها في صفوف جيش الاحتلال ردهم قد
ايه يا دكتور دخل حالي في من السكان يعني
بتكلم عن 600 مثلا اه فهو مش كلهم بيقبلوا
الانضمام للجيش انما في قطاع عريض منهم
بيقبل وللاسف يعني بيقولوا احنا شهداء
الناس الخمسه اللي ماتوا بتوعنا ضم ماتوا
فين ماتوا خ لب حدود مع لبنان ايوه يعني
ماتوا اثناء المواجهات مع مع حزب الله ومع
غزه غزه اه فدي فتحت الجرح احنا دلوقتي
عايزين نخفف قانون القوميه اليهوديه اللي
ما بيعترف بثقافتنا اللي ما بيعترف
بوجودنا خاصه انه في نماذج عنصريه ا في
التمييز مثلا احنا داخلين مكان حساس مفاعل
دايمون مثلا واحنا ضباط في الجيش
الاسرائيلي فانت لا انت بالذات تطلع وبقيت
القو تخش انت ظابط درزي ماش ظابط درزي اه
فانت بالتالي تطلع بره ما تخشش الزياره دي
انت ممنوع ان انت على المدخل فبتحب
الاهانه دي لان مش واثقين فيا وهكذا فده
جزء الجزء اني ان منهم كان عزام عزام
الجاسوس الشهير اللي تجسس على مصر ومصر
القت القبض عليه وطلع في صفقه يعني بعد ان
قد رتح من الزمن والسنوات في
السجون المصريه اللي عايز اضيف ليه ايضا
ان البدو البدو رغم ان هم بيتعرضوا
العنصريه دائمه بسبب الميزانيات الكره
بتاعتهم لا يتم الاعتراف بها كقر فزي
ممثله للقريه اليهوديه فبالتالي بيحصل على
ميزانيه اضعف فده من باب التمييز ضدهم
اللي بيروا ان هو يعني حان الوقت
لتخفيف بعض الشيء اه بعض الشيء يخ هم لان
جزء منهم بيتعاد مع جيش الاحتلال بيموت ما
احنا بنموت يتعاون مع جيش الاحتلال وبيموت
اه فقصص اثر او كذا اذا انت بتتكلم ان في
بعض الفئات بيتم التمييز ضدها اكثر حتى من
الاقليات الاخرى واتكلمت عن الدروس
واتكلمت عن البدو انا بستنجي ان الحديث ار
لانه الاسرائيليين عاوزين اكبر عدد يحارب
معاهم بالبط فاكيد هيست عينوا باي حد
يتعاون معاهم بما فيهم الاقليات اللي هم
بيتعاملوا معاها الاستعلاء زي بعض البدو
زي بعض وعايزين الحريديم اللي ما بيخدموا
يخدموا ان شاء الله يلفوا اغذيه يسوقوا ف
فدول لما بييجوا ينضموا ويتعاونوا من يقبل
منهم التعاون احنا ما بنتكلمش على الكل
يعني فدول بتقول
بيتم التمييز ضدهم وبدا بدات هذه الفئات
تقول قول احنا عاوزين مساواه اكبر
والمساواه دي عشان تتحقق لابد من اعاده
النظر في قانون يهوديه الدوله اللي تم
اقراره سنه 20 واللي بيعتبر المواطن
الاسرائيلي اللي هو الاساسي اليهودي وليس
غيره اه الثقافه والهويه يهوديه عظيم جدا
طيب احنا عندنا ا انتقادات من بعد
الجنرالات المهمين
لخطوه احنا في البدايه رحبنا بها يعني ما
كانش بيسمح نتنياهو اطلاقا بدخول اي وقود
فجاه وجدناه بيظهر ا تفاهم تمام اعتقدنا
ان هو راجل انسان يعني وعاوز ايه يسعف
الحد الادنى من احتياجات هذا القطاع
اكتشفنا ان السبب مالوش اي علاقه
بالفلسطينيين اه هو طلع وعمل تبرير خطير
لان حصل عليه ضغوط هو قال ولا لتر هيخش اه
فابتدا يدخل 25000 لتر كلم على 150,000
لتر فابتدا يبان ان هو في تناقض بين وعوده
وبين منفذه فعايز يبرر فاساء اكثر لنفسه
ولمشد العام ايه هو بقى واللي بيخلق
المجتمع الاسرائيلي ان هو قال انا تعرضت
لضغوط من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكان
الصرف الصحي في غزه
ينفجر فكان هيبقى في اوبئه هينفجر نتيجه
نقص الوقود مابيعملش ا ما فيش مدخت
فبالتالي سينفجر فسيكون هناك اوبئه تنتقل
الى اسرائيل فاسحا بريك وده الراجل اللي
هو بقى مهم دلوقتي ومشهور جنرال من 2018
بيقول ان الجيش الاسرائيلي ماشي غلط
تدريبه غلط وقياداته تم اختيارها بشكل
خاطئ طلع وكتب في معريف قال له هو انت
مستني الولايات المتحده تقول لك ان في
اوبئه هتموتك يعني انت ما عندكش خطه تقول
الخطوه التاليه ليك ايه طب افرض الولايات
المتحده ما طلبتش كنا هنموت احنا من
الاوبا اه ففي تخبط في الخطه عندك بس انا
اللي عندي عندي اهم من كلام بقى التخبط
انه انا اعتقدت في البدايه انه ده استجابه
منطقيه لشيء بديهي لازم القطاع يدخ ب جانب
انسان اشفنا انه المساله ما تهمش خالص
يقتل من يقتل مهم ان لا يمرضوا لان هم
هياثر علينا
بس فطبعا العنصريه
فجه وده اللي المفروض يتم ابرازه ان ده
اللي بن وجهه هو ده يعني بنفس المنطق انا
ماقدرش استخدم السلاح النووي مش لانه ده
لا يصح هتاثر بس اه اه بالضبط انا هتاثر
بس طيب ده ما كانش النقد الوحيد ده كان
احنا برض عندنا ا الجنرال جلعاد اظن جلعاد
عموس اه ده قال ايه مين هو الاول جلعاد
عموس هو جنرال احتياط وهو ليه مواقف
سياسيه ودوما يعني ينتقد نتنياهو و
بالمزايده ان هو لا احنا كان المفروض وكان
مسؤول عن ملفات استخباراتيه وليه باع طويل
يعني في السياسه والعسكريه ف كانت ب ايضا
منتقدا موضوع الوقود وموضوع الخطه العامه
ان انتم هتعملوا ايه في الجنوب اذا كنتوا
انتم في الشمال متعثرين وتم اجلاء عدد
كبير من سكان شمال قطاع غزه ماذا عن
التكدس الموجود حاليا في الجنوب وانتم
بتقولوا نستهدف خانيونس وخان يونس هي اللي
فيها القياده بعد ما كانوا قالوا في
الرنتيسي قالوا لا في الشفا قاله لا في
غزه مدينه غزه مدينه خانيونس فحاليا جنوب
بقى خان يونس هي الهدف وهي الترويج
الاعلامي ليها ان احنا رايحين لخان يونس
لان القياده هناك والرهائن هناك المحتجزين
هناك هو وارد ان يكون تخبط زي ما الجنرال
جلعاد بيقول ووارد حاجه ثانيه لو عندك
تعليق سريع عليها يعني او في حاجه مكتوبه
انه يكون الخطه ان انا بضرب عشوائي بشكل
هائل والحق الاذى بكل المؤسسات مش لان انا
بس مش مش عارف هم فين ولكن ان انا اجعل
منطقه غزه منطقه غير غير صالحه للسكن وكان
هم بيدفعوا بمخطط التهجير بشكل غير مباشر
ما هي النهارده طلعت وزيره المخابرات
الاسرائيليه وهي طبعا كله بيسال يعني هي
شغلتها ايه هي بدون ملفات هي غير مشرفه
على المخابرات فهي من ضمن النشاط يز عنده
وقت فرا كتبت لاسرائيل يوم مقاله ف بتقول
فيها لا التهجير يبقى طوعي ان شاء الله
الموضوع الدول المتعاطفه مع الفلسطينيين
ما يقعدو يتعاطفوا بالكلام
ياخدوه انما احنا مش هنستحمل الاطفال دي
احنا مش هنقدر نتعامل مع الناس دي احنا
خلاص يعني ايه حنى الوقت ان يتم توزيعهم
على دول ا متعاطفه مع فهي الخطه الخطه
الاساسيه باظت الخطه الاساسيه من هذه
الحرب الضغط وفتح الحدود ونقلهم شكل جماعي
الى سينا فابتدا التخبط ده طب نسل لم من
السلطه الفلسطينيه السلطه الفلسطينيه
الاداره بتقول لن استلم بدون القدس
الشرقيه بدون الضفه الغربيه بدون حل شامل
وهم طبعا برض بيقول لك ايه السلطه
الفلسطينيه لازم تتغير احنا سياستها برض
مش عجبانا ما احنا بنضرب في الضفه الغربيه
ليه ما عشان مش
عاجبنا السلطه الفلسطينيه وعشان كده بنضعف
فهو التصور العام ان يجي بقى وكيل عن
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يتولى اداره الضفه
سوري القطاع
سواء بقى قوات دوليه
او اعاده تدوير السلطه الفلسطينيه بحيث ان
يجي حد في قوه دحلان ويشاركوا مروان برغوت
بعد ان يتم التسويق لهمم بعد ان يكون معهم
ميزانيات بعد ان يتم انجاز ما في القدس
الشرقيه او برضو واضح ان هم شغالين على كل
الخطوط زي وزيره الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه
بتقول مش عارف شغلان ايه
انه يعني انا عشان اهيئ الاجواء للهجره
الطبيعيه لازم اخلق اوضاع ماساويه تقنع
دول بالتدخل طب تعال اخد دول ك بان انا
اجعل الاوضاع في غزه الحياه فيها شبه
مستحيله ده برض كده منطقي صحيح صحيح اه
صحيح فهو الكلام ان 80% من قطاع غزه
لاجئين اتوا من النقب فل يعودوا الى النقب
يعني احنا الرد بتاعنا على هذه الروايه
وهذه الترويجات بان اذا كون يعني الوضع لا
يحتمل في غزه ف قبض ارضهم الاساسيه
ويرجعوا يندمجوا وسط البدو وسط التجمعات
بقت خرائب خربه كذا وخربه كذا دي اصلا كره
فلسطينيه تم اجلائهم بالقوه وبتروح في 48
ايه قصص الحاجات اللي بدات تلفت الانتباه
في الاعلام
الاسرائيلي كاثار مباشره للحرب يعني
الاطفال دول اللي غنوا لازم نقتل الجامع
ايه قصتهم يعني هو برض ده من المسكوت عنه
ان المجتمع الاس اسرائيلي بيصور نفسه بان
هو ضحيه اه وفي نفس الوقت عايز يصور نفسه
ان هو جلاد يعني عايز يشتغل مخوفاتي وفي
نفس الوقت ضحيه ان
انا تعاطفوا معايا فوجدوا ان في كراه
الاطفال بيغير كلمات اغنيه الى سنبد العرب
سنقتل جميعا و سنقتل الجميع دي اغنيه اه
فهو يعني ايه براءه القرصان في
عينيه فطبعا كان قالوا لهم دي كارثه
اعلاميه احنا ماشيين في خط وانتم بتشوهوا
اللي احنا بنبنيه ده احنا بنضغط على الامم
المتحده بيقول لهم عدينا اطفال بتقتل
بشوفوا براءه الاطفال انتوا بتقولوا العكس
المثل بتاع سوف نقتل الجميع الاغنيه ديت
ده مثال على وجود متطرفين يعني التطرف
بيزيد اه هو هي اصلا اغاني موجوده اصلا
بيسموها ما فيتل عرا فيم ده جمهور الكرهه
هوه بيتفرج كده بيقول الموت
للعرب طب انت بتتفرج على كوره ايه اللي
دخل العرب ومش الفلسطينيين ومش حماس اه
وبيشتم المسلمين طبعا بالمناسبه وبعد كده
يتف على المسيحيين فهو عنده مشكله اساسيه
مش بيعادي فصيل معين او ليه خصم سياسي
معين هو بيطه الجويين اللي هم الاغيار غير
اليهود ويحتقر السؤال الاخير مع الدكتور
هل في انباء جديده بالنسبه لنا عن
المفاوضات ما بين اسرائيل وحماس عبر وسطاء
متعددين طبعا الجميع يلهس حول اللقطه
الاخيره ان النصر ما يتم تسويقه قبل اتمام
الصفقه انما ملامح الصفقه يعني باتت ظاهره
ويمكن الاشاره اليها بالبنان اللي هي 50
محتجز من الاسرائيليين داخل قطاع غزه كلمه
محتجز دي يقصد بيهم ير العسكريين مدني
يعني سيدات واطفال وناس هو هيبدا ب 50
اطفال ه دول ع هو لما بيقول لي ان لدى
حماس وجماعات اخرى 240 240 عسكري ومدني
ولا 240 عسكري عسكري ومدني عسكري ومدني
هيبدا ب 50 من المدنين اطفال الكلام
دلوقتي الطفل يطلع معاه امه ولا يطلع معاه
اخوه ولا يطلع لوحده عشان الاخراج يبقى
كويس اه الجانب الحمساوي يعني المفاوض
اولا جمد المفاوضات بسبب الانتهاكات ضد
الشفا مجمع كان في خطوط حمراء ا هو
نتنياهو قال اللي ضغطوا علينا عشان ما نخش
بري دخلنا بري ضغطوا عليه عشان ما نخش شفا
انجازات يعني بتاعته ما شاء الله فهو واضح
ان في اتفاقات غير مكتوبه بين حماس وبين
الجانب الاسرائيلي الليبر الوسطاء اه
احيانا يتم انتهاكها فيتم تجميد التفاوض
وما الى ذلك فهو حاليا بيتكلم على 140 طفل
فلسطيني سيتم
الافراج ونساء من سجون الاحتلال بس السؤال
يعني يعني عاده احنا كنا نسمع ان حماس
تطلب مثلا لو عندك جندي او اثنين بتاخد
قدامهم مئات ليه هي موافقه على 50 محتجزين
والمدنيين والرهائن ولا ايا كان الاسم في
الاخر هم بالنسبه له غزه كلها بتضرب سؤال
مهم ليه بتقبل في يعني في مقابله عدد
محدود مقارن بالصفقات السابقه واحد لان ده
عبق بعضهم محتاج رعايه طبيه الجزء الثاني
ان جزء اخلاقي واعلامي ان انت ليه محتجز
اطفال مش مش لطيف ان انت معاك سلاح الي
وواقف جنبك طفل وبتديها ماء او تحاول
تهديه المنظر بتاع السلاح ده اصلا بيروه ف
هو عبق اعلامي واخلاقي لدرجه الجانب الصي
بيقول خلاص خدهم ببلاش ده يعني بدون مقابل
ا ف الجانب الحمساوي يرى بان التذكره بان
وجود اطفال
داخل سجون الاحت تلال ده مكسب بس سؤال اذا
كانت اذا كانوا هم في حوزه كتائب القسام
او حماس معنى ذلك ان هم مش الاهالي اللي
خدوهم لا هو ليه مخرج للحكايه دي قال انا
هطلع على دفعات دوني فرصه هدن علشان خمسه
ايام علشان اوصل وامن الخروج والناس ما
تبقاش خايفه الناس مش مرتبكه واجمع
معلومات هخرج ال 50 على دفعات اذا وفقا
لفهمك ومتابعتك لما يحدث انه هؤلاء
المدنيين او المح زين او غير العسكريين ما
كانوش الهدف الاساسي للكتائب القسا اتى
بهم جمعات واهالي مختلفين في الفوضه التي
حدثت سحيح قد يكون له سجين داخل بدون
محاكمه داخل حوافز كتيره
وانه الحماس بتقول انا عاوز الهدن ديت
علشان طبعا هي تستفيد من الهدن ولكن كمان
علشان انا اقدر اتواصل بمعلوماتي واقدر
اجيب هؤلاء المحتجزين لدى اسر كثيره اه هو
الفكره كمان ان حتى المعلومات يقوللك
هتديني اصد
انا مش هقول لك الرقم النهائي انا مش عارف
الر معلما معلومات الجانب الاسرائيلي
بيطلب معلومات مين عايش مين ميت العد
النهائي كام قالله اديني فرصه ان انا اوصل
للناس واكلمهم اتاكد عايز ايه بقى انا
قصاد المعلومات دي عايز حاجات حاجات زي
ايه بقى زي وقود زي هدنه زي خطوط حمراء
انها مش هنخش كذا لا هنطلع من كذا يعني
تسريع وتيره التفاوض ان نتكلم ان احنا
نبقى شريك في اداره القطاع في المستقبل
ضمانات بالنسبه للقاده بالنسبه للتمويل
احنا محتاجين مين اللي هيرم القطاع بعد
اعاده الاعمار تفاصيل دي تمويل وده مساله
ا طرحت مساله تمويل او اعاده الاعمار اه
ما هو طبعا عشان طرحت وزيره الجيله الجملا
وزيره الاستخبارات قالت بدل ما تصرف فلوس
خذوا تصرف فلوس في غزه بتقول مين هو مين
عرض اه ما هو التركيا من ضمن الحاجات يعني
اردوغان استبق الاحداث وقال انا هنشارك في
عياده اعمار غزه اه انما هو احنا دلوقتي
بنوقف الدم اللي بيسيل يعني احنا بننقل
الناس طبعا اردوغان عليها علامه استفهام
كثيرا ان بيصدر خضروات الى الجانب
الاسرائيلي يعني الاغاثه بتصل للجانب
الاسرائيلي من خلال سفن بتصل لحيفا وطبعا
الجانب الاسرائيلي كمان بيقول قطعوا
البضايع التركيه ده الراجل ده معادي لينا
وقطعا تركيا موقفها علامه استفهام واكبر
علامه استفهام انه قال انا ل اقطع
العلاقات مع اسرائيل اه احنا عايزين وبرر
ده بانه لازم يكون قرار جماعي لكن علامه
الاستفهام
صاف ايو ليست على موقف تركيا واحده هو
محور المقاومه هو مدهش صادم لا والله
والدول العربيه عشان اكون امول العربيه
يعني عمات الاستف اي شكرا جزيلا مع شكرا
لحضرتك سيد وبالتوفيق ويا رب يتم لجم
العدوان في اسرع وقت ربنا يخليك ذك شكرا
جزيلا لحضراتكم والقاكم في حلقات الاخرى
باذن الله